[Musique]
aujourd'hui je partage avec vous un bon
plan c'est une application qui va
franchement vous arrangez vous
solutionner pas mal de problèmes c'est
une application qui est dédié aux
automobilistes alors je vous explique
l'application s'appelle zen par le
constat de base c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
de parkings privés qui sont forcément
vide il ya beaucoup de te la santé
parking privé qu'ils sont vacantes et
dans certains cas de l'autre côté c'est
très compliqué trouve une place soit
dans des parkings qui coûte franchement
cher ou alors des places dans la rue
c'est assez compliqué pas partout mais
dans beaucoup d'endroits et je pense
notamment aux grandes agglomérations
l'originalité de l'offre est ce qui
différencie zen par quatre des parkings
classique c'est de rendre accessibles
des places de parking dans des
résidences des hôtels des supermarchés
des lieux inaccessibles à la base au
grand public et des tarifs hyper
compétitif jusqu'à 70 % moins cher que
la voirie et à partir de 30 centimes de
l'heure vous allez pouvoir réserver à
leurs prolonger facilement si vous avez
besoin d'un peu plus de temps ou bien
encore faire de la location au moisn
parc c'est aussi près de 600 parking en
france et en belgique
c'est une solution on pratique pas cher
flexible et c'est pour ça que vous en
parle je ne sais pas si ça vous arrive
est tourné pendant des heures pour
trouver une place de parking et galérer
pour au final réussir à trouver une
place
des fois un peu limite et franchement
c'est galère là pour le coup justement
je trouve que l'idée vraiment bonne
deuxième pack et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous parle de cette
application c'est que avant même de
partir vous savez exactement où vous
allez vous garez vous savez combien ça
va vous coûter
et ça franchement c'est un bon je vous
montre comment ça marche l'application
c'est celle là ici la zale parcs ou des
vous allez voir que vous créez un petit
compte ça va extrêmement vite ce que
vous faites si vous allez chercher à
quel endroit vous voulez allez bon par
exemple moi je sais pas je vais taper
égard up début allez on va regarder tout
à l'heure date de début aller vers 13h45
ok je confirme fin et je vais me dire
que j'en ai pour
deux heures type de véhicule à les
véhicules moyens je cherche une place là
ça ne va pas trop mal
j'en ai un qui a 100 m mais qui pour
deux heures va me coûter 2 euros donc ça
fait 1 euro de l'heure là c'est pareil
et là je suis à 60 centimes de l'heure
c'est merveilleux ça me va très bien les
bills j'ai le plan j'ai les infos
l'heure de début lors de faim moyens
d'accès avec mon application on va les
voir on va les tester c'est génial un
petit descriptif ici qui me dit tout sur
le lieu où je veux aller ce que je peux
visiter à côté ça pour le tourisme c'est
vraiment cool et ensuite à leurs
caractéristiques
ça c'est bien aussi hauteur maximale à
mettre 90 c'est bon ça passe couvert
sous terrain éclairé tout va bien il n'y
a pas de vidéo surveillance que c'est un
parking couvert donc ça ne va pas trop
mal mon pouce edge moor figeant les
paras voiturier j'en ai pas besoin
j'ai ici la photo les photos du lieu
avec la signalétique donc sans le verrez
exactement sur place deux roues petite
voiture moyenne ok ça me va bien
allez on y va réserver réservations
réussit bien effectué vous pouvez dès à
présent la retrouver dans votre liste
des réservations
donc là j'ai une liste des réservations
g l'itinéraire je peux prolonger si ce
souhait talent l'itinéraire ça c'est du
google maps donc ça montre vraiment
l'itinéraire pour pouvoir y aller
pratiquer cette voir si jamais je veux
prolonger comment je fais je sortirai du
parking 15 minutes plus tard 30 minutes
une heure deux heures plus tard
sélectionnez la face au tc vraiment pas
mal c'est vraiment très très
personnalisable je trouve ça vraiment
bien j'ai mes abonnements donc là c'est
pareil je peux avoir un abonnement
chercher une place vrai j'ai des tarifs
par mois c'est pas hyper cher alors ça
dépend effectivement où on veut aller ce
qu'on veut ça dépend de nos besoins j'ai
ici mon profil moyen de paiement mais
immatriculations mac consommation
récente parrainage code promo code promo
et oui code promo moi je vais aller
l'essayer d'ici quelques instants mais
vous aussi vous allez pouvoir l'essayer
zèle pas que vous offre 5 euros de
crédits pour votre utilisation avant le
31 décembre de cette année ça me
permettra d'aller faire votre shopping
de noël tranquillement ça c'est plutôt
cool bravo à nos parcs le code c greuze
vous retrouvez en bas en descriptions
l'application fonctionne bien évidemment
sur android mais également sur ios
donc là on à l'appli juste la
réservation itinéraire itinéraire ça
m'ouvre google maps 11 minutes à pied
cinq minutes en bagnole c'est formidable
lionel garrigues alors landes plus être
bien bien loin alors on est à deux rues
doivent savoir que je cherche la
signalétique zen parc ça doit être
affichée de partout à l'extérieur
identifier donc ça c'est plutôt cool
et puis ensuite on est loin de là tout
un balisage à l'intérieur donc s'en va
le regarder alors je tiens à rassurer
que voyager mais demain là donc ce n'est
pas moi qui filme merci les eaux dans la
nuit à droite du mercato mais roquet a
tancé pas la note là la jeanne d'arc
alors là normalement je vais sur mon
appli j'ai mes réservations depuis su
rentrer et sortir entrer en voiture
les places se trouve au rez de chaussée
si vous vous garer dans le parking
inférieur les places se trouvera au
moins deux d'avoir une signalétique dans
l'album tard galles j'ai déjà une place
là mais moi je mettrais intérieur - 2
vous êtes par la géniale à plate
réserver une part elle elle est déjà
booké il ya une voiture au saut là il y
en a une autre dans la tente
yes la place jeanne d'arc alors on y va
on se gare franchement la solution est
hyper hyper fier papa t'es arrivé
maintenant elle se faire un petit
débrief à l'extérieur
au final signalétique vraiment hyper
pratique dès qu'on arrive un parking on
à la signalétique vous la suivez vous
êtes vraiment guidé par pas ça c'est
franchement cool on va même jusqu'à la
sortie piétons comme ça au moins vous
est pris par la main et vous n'avez plus
qu'à faire je trouve que l'idée vraiment
bien pourquoi parce que effectivement
vous trouver des places de parking
libres que vous pouvez réserver la danse
vous n'allez pas tourné pendant des
heures a galéré pour trouver une place
de parking
en plus c'est pas cher et ce qui est
bien c'est qu'une fois que vous y êtes
si vous avez un impondérable a duré plus
longtemps vous avez du shopping vous
avez pas fini parce que vous voulez vous
êtes au cinéma qui après vous faire une
bonne bouffe entre potes avec votre ami
vous fasse que vous voulez brestois ne
nous regarde pas ben vous pouvez le
faire et ça je dois reconnaître que
c'est vraiment vraiment tout cas une
super bonne idée puis je pense que ça
permettra un petit peu de désengorger un
peu les centres-villes où il n'ya pas de
place donc ça c'est un excellent point
d'ailleurs je vous invite à tester
parce que zen parc vous offre 5 euros de
crédit à ces com com passe partout 5les
vous offre 5 euros de crédits vous avez
le code dreux grrr
vous avez le code en bas des
inscriptions valable jusqu'au 31
décembre pour faire votre shopping à
noël vous pouvez y aller c'est
franchement cool
il est l'heure de sortir du parking
sortie en voiture vous lie à gauche
c'est magnifique
regardez-moi ça
tu as une place c'est juste la canaille
note la jeune encore une autre là bas à
droite c'est pas mieux
on n'arrête pas le progrès donc tu as
entre l entrée la voiture sortir en
voiture mais aussi sortir à pied parce
que les accès quand vous sortez d'une
résidence au pjak est sécurisé et
forcément il faut pouvoir rentrer et
sortir vous pouvez déverrouiller la
première barrière la deuxième barrière
puis ensuite les portes d'accès
intérieur ça c'est aussi bien bien
réfléchi que le système en tout cas
vraiment bien trouver de la part de nos
parcs
c'est très malin bien fait l'idée c'est
effectivement va pouvoir garer votre
voiture facilement on vous voulez ça
c'est franchement génial je trouve que
le système est vraiment bien
physiquement vous ce que vous en pensez
en commentaire est ce que vous pourriez
utiliser ce que vous l'utilisez de ce
tout savoir si vous remarquez mort et de
l'amour
voilà pour les sages à bientôt